oh we need coffee enema this is
disgusting what is the truth what is
this
I should not be drinking coffee right
now it's like 3 p.m. and I've had at
least three times already I only have
one I'm a 1 coffee a day girl most times
I'm Dominican we wake up that's the
first thing we make cafe and I Kappa
theta oh you know hey should we make
coffee
different dip the bread inside for about
30% of the population coffee acts as a
laxative in other words it makes you
poop all day oh yeah I can attest to
this one for sure I don't have the same
reaction I wish I did I'm like coffee
strong as your coffee is strong I don't
need to juice click legend has it that
President Theodore Roosevelt consumed
almost a gallons worth of coffee every
day what you'd be so gallant he be a lot
yeah yeah yeah what coffee has been
linked to numerous health benefits but
according to the British Medical Journal
you have to drink three to four cups
without clean more sugar to get the most
out of your coffee what would be the
benefit of dream four cups of coffee a
caffeine addiction I drink that strong
so might as well like one worker
yeah woke up is four cups so I am
healthier first time let me put in my
sugar in there a cup of coffee consumed
even six hours before bedtime can
disrupt your sleep if I drink after 6:00
I'm I'm not going to sleep what about oh
man no it's 5:30
I forgot it's 5:30 I'm gonna be up this
is a fact we all know and ignore nor F
it bedtime all right next one in 17th
century England coffee was touted as a
cure for alcoholism tated what word is
this stopped its target I wouldn't trust
17th century England with most and when
the FDA states seconds to me too much
caffeine as in more than four hundred
milligrams or four to five cups per day
can cause jitter anxiousness trouble
sleeping nausea upset stomach headaches
increased heart rate and dysphoria I'm
just gonna throw out there that some of
these vaccine conflicting first of all I
don't know what the FDA is talking about
you see mr. Nelson coffee makes you
happy in 2014 a Canadian man
alleged that he purchased a cup of
coffee for McDonald's and as he removed
the lid to get no no God as he removed
the lid to get the last drop he found a
dead mouse inside along with the mouse
top you didn't feel that shaking around
and you're cut off if this had a rat in
it I think I would feel it so he found
the a mouse inside and also with the
mouse poops I wonder what was more
flavorful May was delicious
legend has it that many years ago some
people considered the coffee that drink
of the devil but after one sip the Pope
declared the drink too delicious
only for sinners so he blasted that's my
Pope bless up he should have done the
same for sex heart failure may be
prevented or postponed with one or two
cups of coffee a day half of these are
like drink cofee it's good for you and
the other half for like stopping that
you're gonna die that's all of my
passions a very conflicting the caffeine
and coffee may provide some protection
from Alzheimer's and Parkinson's disease
oh no freakin way
frickin a man if you have more than one
risk factor for heart disease and are
not a regular coffee drinker you might
be at a heightened risk for heart attack
within the hour of consuming coffee yeah
so like it could benefit your heart and
also it could kill your heart coffee
enemas are not safe and can even be
deadly people put up their Bo home yeah
boy are you serious
no more needs to be said that subject I
learned a lot about coffee which I'm
happy about
I feel like there was a lot more good
things and bad things yeah coffee it's
fun and my drink Starbucks I feel like a
rich upper class white girl I think that
there's probably benefits for some
people and negatives for others Dairy
can kill some people and like soak in
nuts so I think it just depends on your
own health and you know yourself best
just know your body Oh
[Music]